my name is dawn Paley I'm a freelance
journalist and I just put out my first
book called drug war capitalism critics
of the drug war will often criticize the
drug war as being a failure because the
amount of cocaine for example reaching
the United States hasn't been reduced
even though billions of dollars have
been spent on that pretext and what I
argue in the book is that in reality it
hasn't been a failure because I think
the metrics that we need to be using to
measure the success that drug war are
more aligned with u.s. foreign policy
generally and less aligned with you know
drugs so you know if you look at the
impacts of drug war in terms of its
ability to you know create and guarantee
new spaces for investment by private
corporations if you look at Colombia and
you look at Mexico you'll see that
actually the drug war has been a huge
success so in the past couple of years
in Mexico there's been a huge amount of
forms past has been financial reform
education reform tax reform energy
reform telecommunications reforms other
reforms all these reforms have been
passed now while the people in Mexico
are totally distracted by the security
situation and many of them are supported
by US funded lobby groups and that
funding is now all channeled through you
know the Merida Initiative at the US
Embassy in Mexico City
I don't think official death toll
numbers are to be trusted in any state
at war with its people but in Mexico the
numbers have been sitting around 60,000
dead and drug-related violence for a
couple years now we know that's simply
not the case in my book I refer to the
number of homicides since 2006 since the
drug where drug war was declared that
number sits at 150,000 and you have to
keep in mind that you know they only
count dead when there's a body the other
piece there is that you know migrants
and people that aren't Mexicans that
don't have status in Mexico don't enter
adult figure into the death counts
following the disappearance of the 43
students from iguala guerrero on
september 26th 27th authorities been
looking for the students and what
they've been finding is grave after
grave after grave containing multiple
bodies we actually don't know how many
bodies they haven't told us but we know
they're not the bodies of the students
and you know this is actually one of the
first times they've been looking for
mass graves in Mexico and it's like they
were finding like one or two a day right
so the entire country is a cemetery is
actually one of the sayings that people
have been chanting it at demos and so on
what they tend to do is dig out the
bodies sometimes they even use
caterpillars and heavy machinery to get
them out
identify 11 percent of them the rest are
reburied in state-run mass graves and I
don't think there's any way to interpret
that really other than being away for
this you know that the state is covering
the tracks and the criminals be they you
know the army the police or organized
crime groups destroying the possibility
of learning more about these crimes and
nature of these crimes and maybe one day
holding somebody responsible for them
you